years ago famed country singer
songwriter and Nobel Prize winner Bob
Dylan said that he had made a deal with
something a long time ago Dylan said it
was to get where he is now his Fame
success accolades and enormous musical
Talent Dylan said he had made a bargain
with the chief of this world this earth
and the world we cannot see that he had
traveled to the crossroads and made a
deal with something and when he came
back he was the man he is today Dylan
was performing Feats of musical skill
his friends couldn't believe and another
friend even referred to him as a shape
changer or a manp possessed but who was
this chief of the earth and the world we
cannot see it would be natural to assume
that Dylan was referring to God right
well the New Testament poses another
idea that it is the devil not God who is
the prince of this world